Thank you.
All right, guys.
I think we are hopefully live.
Let me know if you guys can hear me.
I'm going to do the everyone tag.
Boom.
There's that.
All right.
Let me bring.
Hey, guys.
All right.
Awesome.
Okay.
Let me know if you guys can hear me.
Um,
And.
There we go.
There it is.
All right.
Waiting for, um,
Give me a few seconds here.
I want to get you guys set up.
Um,
This is going to be our new search.
Um, campaign.
That we've been talking about doing.
This is going to be a website traffic one.
Not a call one.
Um,
Okay.
There's Francesca.
Hey, Francesca.
Are you coming on?
Let me know if you can hear me.
Hello.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yes.
I know.
Aren't they all.
Okay.
Um,
All right.
I think I got us on here.
Let me check.
Um,
The group, make sure there's nobody with any questions.
Josh is asking and can't tune in for this stream. Yes.
This is going to be penned hopefully to the top or one of the other
websites.
Um,
And then, um,
We'll be building on this again.
I kept told everybody.
We're going to be, uh, making.
Uh, like better, more polished versions for this,
that we can dive deeper into things on.
That'll eventually get added to the backside of the website.
But for right now, we're just putting this up here so you guys can get
going.
And you don't have to wait on us and things getting edited and
Um,
I think that's kind of where we're at.
Just give me one quick second here.
I find that the, um,
Well, I think the last time I told you,
it's like super delayed between Facebook and us.
It's weird.
Yeah.
So questions come in later.
So I, I'm going to pull this up on my phone.
And this silence it, but it's just, uh,
It's weird.
Right.
That was like 10 seconds ago.
I know it's weird.
It's super weird.
Okay.
I'm just going to leave this off to the side.
So if I see.
Uh, chats come in, they can pick them up.
All right.
Um, okay. So today we're going to set up.
Uh, another search campaign.
Uh, earlier today I went on and I made the changes to the call
only ad that we did for the new Orleans duck work.
Um, so I set those up.
And we're going to be, um,
Doing the same thing to this one in like a week or two, right?
Cause those are, as you know, with your experience,
like that's just a common thing.
And it's one of the negative drawbacks of the search campaigns for
sure.
Um, okay. So with that, we're going to do.
Screen share.
I'm so slow at this stuff today. All right.
I feel like I've been like on the phone or zooms all day today.
And I feel like I've done nothing.
So, um,
I'm sure you've done a lot.
My checking account does not agree.
Um,
Anyways, it's been maintenance day.
I feel like today's been maintenance day, but that's, that's just happens.
All right. Um,
Okay. So before we dive into this one,
Let's see, Jason has a question and I have a new question.
I just joined the group about two weeks ago for unpaid balance.
The appeal date times.
You know,
Yeah, Jason, that's totally normal. Oh no. Unpaid balance. Oh,
Uh,
My experience with the unpaid balance thing is, um,
If you search the group,
you'll see a bunch of chats about it like from like a year or two ago.
But typically what's like,
there's something that's tied to your Gmail or a credit card or something
like deep inside the world that Google could be store music,
YouTube or something.
So if you, if you're looking for unpaid balance,
like you're looking for something that's like,
I'm looking for something, um,
getting you a gift card,
something that's like got a weird balance on it.
And that's what's holding you up.
So just check that go back through your history.
And, um, eventually you'll be able to find it. Okay.
Hopefully that helps, but.
It does happen. You just gotta go find it.
I've had stuff for like 72 cents.
But I don't know.
So.
All right.
So we'll, we'll hop in. If you have anything, you know, the rules, just yell, scream, stop me.
If I start getting too nerdy or not into something like make sure we,
we bring it back around. So, all right. Okay. Let's get started. Okay, guys. So we're going
to set up a, it's a different type of search campaign. The first one that we set up is a call
only ad. So today we're going to set up one. That's going to be a website traffic ad, but it's
good. It still has the options to get calls. It's just, it's just displayed a little differently.
They're both valuable in a perfect world. I would set up call only and the website traffic, but
sometimes when you do that, you like double your ad spend. So for today, today we're going to do,
we're going to set up a one for an Atlanta towing site. This is a one pager,
right? Super simple. We only one pager for towing. Obviously like call only would be better
for towing, but we're going to set this up with website traffic. And then I can always change
this later on the other end of it, but for display purposes, we're going to do this. So
we've created the campaign, right? We do that just like in the, in the original training,
you go to your MCC, you set up your sub account, and then you go from there.
Okay. So we're going to set up new campaign. Okay. We're going to come to here. It's going
to ask us like what our guidance is, right? So we're going to select website traffic.
And then it's going to ask us what platform we want to be on. And we're going to say search.
Okay. Now it's going to ask our website. We're going to go here.
We're going to copy that. We're going to paste that in. We're going to say, yeah, man,
page view for sure. Then we're going to put here.
This stuff right here, like I'm not a huge fan of giving Google all my data
because we're doing Legion, but you do you.
Okay. Bidding. You could do conversions or clicks. I prefer to do max clicks, especially
at the beginning as I'm getting data. I'm then a fan at like month three or four moving into
conversions, because there's going to be all of this data that Google's compiled. And then it's
going to help me do better conversion rates. If my experience, my opinion is if you set
conversions up in the beginning, Google's going to waste more of your money. So I'm not a fan.
So I go here. I go to clicks. Okay. Now what I want to do is I want to set a maximum cost per
click because Google is going to always want to spend my money. It'll give me $30 clicks,
$40 clicks or whatever. So in this campaign, I have several keywords that Francesca provided me.
I just did Mangles. I set it up over Atlanta. You can use SEMrush. I just prefer Mangles for local
because I use Ahrefs for like other stuff. So the one I put in was towing. That's right here.
You can see the CPC, the search volume, and then these are some of my other keywords that we're
going to use. And you can see search volume and CPC. Now this is what Mangles says. This has been
a question I've seen a couple of times. SEMrush says this. Mangles says that. But then it's actually
this. Okay. But remember, this is used as a guidance. This tells us if it's good or not
or if we want to, you know, kind of what to expect or budget for. But when I'm actually here,
okay, when I'm actually in here, what I'm going to do is I'm going to go to my tools and settings.
I'm going to click it. I'm going to go to my keyword planner. I'm going to right click that.
I'm going to open it in a new link. Okay. I'm going to hit discover new keywords and then I'm going to
do a couple of different. What was one? Keys locked in car? Locked keys. Oh yeah. Locked car keys.
Something like that. And then I'm going to change this to Atlanta.
I have specific like areas in Atlanta. Do you want me to tell you or we can go back and do that later?
We will do that, but let's do that a little later. Because what this step is, that's a good
question. This step is just trying, we're trying to like get what Google is going to tell us our
high and low range of CPC so we can set our max limit. And so we don't have to be as specific as
unless you're like going to go completely outside of the metro area, then we don't necessarily need
that. Does that make sense? It's like if we were going to run it in like Stone Mountain, but call
it Atlanta, then we would definitely want to look over that area. But if we're going to be in and
around this area, that's fine. It's like the New Orleans one where we like, we just use New Orleans
because that's going to have the most data, right? Yeah. Okay. So we hit save and then we hit get
results. Okay. And then here we go. So remember like that 1,600, like those are similar
results on what I saw here, maybe a little bit more, a little bit. Yeah, similar, close enough,
not totally off. Okay. And then I'm going to go here and it's going to be a little bit more
high and top of page bid low. In a perfect world, we always want to be higher than the high bid,
but you can see like, these are like $2 higher than what we got from Mangles right now for some of
these keywords. It's not that one's better or one's worse. It's just, these are just differences in
the tools. And then we're going to go ahead and hit save and then we're going to go ahead and hit
it. It's not that one's better or one's worse. It's just, these are just differences in the tools.
But I like to go here and just see what CPC is like, I want to spend $15 for locked car keys.
Maybe, maybe not. I don't know what the customer makes on it. So, but I also see how low that is.
And then I look at these at being like $8, $7, $8. What's this one, another car locksmith. Okay. So
the locksmith ones are higher. That's fine. We want to get those, the tow jobs, mostly these
guys like doing the tow jobs. Sometimes there's people that are specific about getting keys out
and all that. So what we'll do is we look around here. So it looks like $8, $7, I see $9 record
service. That's, that's going to be typically like that term is typically like a bigger tow service
or bigger tow truck. So just looking around, let's see.
Okay. So I'm going to kind of use like this one. So we're going to choose $8.75 as our max click,
because that's about, that'll put me a penny higher than a majority of what these main keywords are.
Okay. So I'm going to go back to here and then hit and that's that. Okay. So I hope that's,
hope you guys understand why we're doing that. And, and we'll go from there.
Eman Coles asks, can we do an analytics and GTM conversion tracking overview for calls and forms?
Yeah, I, yeah, we can set that up for a future office hours. I'm not going to do it today though.
Okay. Now with towing, like this is one that's interesting for like towing,
you can set up only bid for new customers, but I always figure like if someone's like looking
and then they go to look and they come back, like you don't want that ad to not be displayed to them
when they're going to make the call. So I kind of leave it off. It becomes an issue. Then we'll,
we'll change it. Then you go here. So the next step it's going to remember it's going to be on
the search network, but look at this, even here, they want to automatically put you on the search
partners and display network, but we were going to get off of those. So we uncheck those and then
it's going to ask us for our locations. Okay. So here we're going to hit enter location
and then Francesca, you have a few sites for us, right? Yes. Let me pull it up.
It's in my email. Just give me one second.
Okay. So I have
Lake city, which I have no idea what it's at.
Does it exist?
Yep. There it is. Funny how as I typed it in, it gave me a zip code.
Yeah. Then there's east point.
There it is. East point, Georgia. Then I have union city.
Okay. And then he just said college. I wonder if,
if it's that college park that I saw earlier, when you type the union city.
That's it. Yeah. Okay. All right. Okay.
Okay. We could definitely run it. I mean, we have some good, we have some,
we have some good numbers there. Like there's some stretches here of like the interstate.
I'm trying to remember. It's been so long since I've done anything in Atlanta.
Can you do it by, should we do it by radius or not really?
Well, we could, but like, you know, there's areas of Atlanta he may not want to serve or go into,
because it's kind of a pain in the butt getting around there. So
um, there's no way for us to like,
and dry. Um, well, yeah, we can. It's just, we don't know where he wants to go. That's specific
where he wants to go, but like, we can make like, um, yeah, if you, I'll tell you what, um,
maybe after this call, if you want to like, maybe talk to him or met tomorrow or something and just,
just ask, like, do you want those specific locations or is there like a radius you want
to set up? You can just tell them like, Hey, like something like, Hey, we're, we want to set up
getting some ads going just to like, get you some quick wins while we're ranking stuff. Like, you
know, I got these areas, but is there like a certain like region or, or, you know, maybe give
them some of these other names that you see and see if he's cool with that. Cause sometimes people
are like, Oh, I don't want to go into that neighborhood at all. Um, so you can hit them up.
Yeah. And they will make changes on that. Is that okay? Yeah. Okay. Cause this is a pretty
good population with right now. So, um, okay, we go to there. So we set that up everybody. Um,
and then we go to location options. And now towing is an interesting one because like,
we want to do like typically like presence of like people in or regularly in the targeted area,
but a towing, like, especially near an airport, like you could have tourists,
you can have people there for business. You can have, you know, uh, family members watching
people play sports, like playoffs are coming up, like all sorts of stuff. So like in this particular
one, typically like for our like home service technicians, we want to have the presence one
right here. We want that one targeted because we don't want that, but for towing, cause those
people want it now. We don't really care where they're at. We just want them in our area.
So this one, we might want to try this presence or interest. So people that are like,
like here and they're interested in that, that might be something to play with on a towing niche.
But for right now, I'm just going to turn this on and we'll see if we need to switch it later.
Okay. And languages, English, the audience segment, like we're not really getting involved with that
with what we're doing. Okay. We want this off and we go here. Um, Francesca, 24 hour towing.
Yeah. Cool. All right. And then we hit next. Okay. I'm going to go up here and we're going
to add our keywords and stuff. Okay. And now it's going to add, it's going to add that one.
Here's all of Google's keywords that they want to, that they want to do. Um, those are interesting.
Okay. All right. So I've put in, um, the main ones here that Francesca gave me, um, into this
website, add this AdWords wrapper. And this helps me do a proper format that I don't have to
like, um, go into here and like Adam and put the quotations or the brackets or whatever.
And just as a reminder, when I have like a word that has nothing around it, that's called the
broad match. When I have it with the quotation marks around it, that's called the phrase match.
And when I have these brackets around it, that's called an exact match. Um, broad match means like
anything closely related to that. It's going to show an ads on. That's like what we saw
with the search campaigns. If I put quotations around it,
what that's saying is like, let's say I typed in, like, what is the best 24 seven roadside
assistance near me? My ads going to show, because that phrase is included in the search query.
If I put the bracket around it, it's only going to show up for that exact search query. Okay.
I prefer for lead gen and what we're trying to do and getting some data is the phrase match.
You can always make tweaks later. Um, you can do broad match, but I only do that if I just have
zero idea what's going to work or not. And I just want to see what sticks. Okay. But typically
that's going to be a big waste of ad spend. Um, okay. So we're going to go here. I go here and
click wrap keywords, wraps, my keywords. I go here where it says phrase match. I'm going to
click wrap keywords, wraps, my keywords. I go here where it says phrase match. It's
formatted in for me. I select it. I copy it. I go back. I go back here. Um, I'm going to
do this real quick before I delete those other ones. Um, and Francesca with this, like these
24 hour ones, were you guys getting any, um, like 24 hour stuff on your search terms?
I just want to make sure that we have. Yeah. Yeah. I'm going to try. I'm going to add like
road service. That's, that's probably a decent one. Um, maybe keys locked in car.
So sometimes Google doesn't give you good suggestions, but for something like this,
it's like, that might be, might be helpful. Um, especially like the overnight hour,
someone's going to be looking for like that all day one, you know? Um,
okay. So you guys can see like, right, we're just kind of adding them. You can see that I'm
putting these quotations on them. Right. And so like road service, keys locked in car, like,
you know, that'll, that phrase match will cover 24 hour, 24 seven. Um, you know,
who can get my keys locked in my car? Like type of thing, you know, those type of phrases,
roadside assistance. I think we already got roadside. Do you have roadside? Let's do roadside.
Yeah, we have roadside. All right. Cool. Okay. Now I'm going to delete all these
Google suggested ones because Google likes money.
Okay. So we're going to set those up. Okay. And now
I'm going to hit, I can have that set. I'm going to go down here real quick. I'm just going to hit
done. It's just like my stupid way of saving it. Okay. All right. Um, okay. So now we're going to
go up here. We got towing Atlanta. We believe, and we can just put, um, like towing services.
Okay. And now it's going to ask for headlines. And just like in the last time we want to try
to get this to like good or to excellent good is going to be about three fourths of the way
around the circle. Excellent. It's going to be all the way around the circle. Um, we definitely
want those to be there and we add headlines that are, um, that are geared towards our
main keywords and or services. Um, sometimes if you're not sure, like, um, Google will make
some suggestions for you. Okay. And you can use some of those and, um, and then get that going
for you. So, um. May not allow that, but we're going to see if it'll let me keep the 24 seven
that.
Okay.
Remember how we were doing this the other day? Like they give you these,
like they give you some of these to use, which are great
if they coincide with your website, your web headlines and your keywords. It's great.
Um, do they do gas service, gas fuel? Like, do they bring gasoline?
I don't know if that's the actual search term used, but that's what Google picked up. So I'm
just going to go with it now and we'll double check it. As you know, like once we set this up
a couple, two, three days later, it'll tell us something. It'll make different suggestions
for us, but we'll try to do that. Um, let's see. Okay. That's awesome. You guys hear the
gardener? Go inside and listen to kids. Can you hear the gardener next door?
I don't. Oh, good. Okay. Maybe these headphones work. Awesome.
Is this person a AAA roadside? Do they take AAA? Do you know?
No, no. Okay. I'll put it on the list of things to ask.
Okay.
Let's see what other keywords can we throw in there?
I'll leave space for like the AAA. If you can find that out, that'd be cool.
Um, maybe like affordable towing. That's not really a big one to trick service.
Do you know if they have like heavy equipment, like heavy wreckers or like are they just doing
cars? Do you know? Um, well, like accidents. Yeah. Sometimes like, like some, some local areas,
like a wrecker will be like certain type of tow trucks. Sometimes they're the bigger ones or
like they have the cranes on them or the booms or something. I have to ask. Okay.
Okay. I would, yeah, I would leave it if you want.
Yeah. Okay. Let's see. What else can we do here?
Boom.
We'll see if I can get one.
There you go. Um,
like did you already put flat tire, um, like repair or something like that? So I think you put.
I think I did. I put something. I put flat tire replacement. I'll put flat tire repair.
And I'm going to leave this one open in case we do AAA or like an insurance brand or something.
I'll leave that one open, but we're already at excellent. So that's good.
Um, and we didn't even try a description yet. Um, okay. Do you guys have, I know you guys have used
towing before. Do you guys have some descriptions that you've used in the past that you're aware of?
The only, um, till we know we do, we actually don't even run ads anymore.
But I can.
That's okay. I'm going to stop the share real quick and I'm going to go through my computer.
Fine. Some stuff that I've written down. Well, we may have.
I'll bring my screen back up. Everybody. I'm just moving stuff around in my window. So,
and then I'll share it again.
Like when I don't know, I just use Nick's stuff because it works.
Don't know why it works, but it works. Right. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Here we are. We are back. Okay. So we just, I just copied, uh,
what we use right with the group. So, um, that's fine. Uh, we specialize and
and towing
not keys,
but tire repair
and more call for free quote, the local, affordable
professional, the truck company
and the Atlanta area. Okay. So we'll call those good for right now. We'll come up with some other
ones later, um, and do that. Okay. So for everyone following along. So, so far, we've set everything
up. Um, we spent the time to put in the headlines. It showed you how like Google will help you
sometimes. Sometimes it doesn't, but a lot of times it does. But you want to remember, like we
also went into keyword planner, where I looked at some volume and stuff and I'm able to see some of
the main keywords and I just use some variants. And just by doing that, I'm going to be able to
keywords and I just use some variants. And just by doing that, like I already started off my ad
strength into excellent, which is good in three, four days, it's going to be different, but it's
always helpful to start off there. And then you can always change it from there. The descriptions
that just stick with the simple one that works. You don't have to get too fancy, but you can do
that. Um, so because this is a, a single, um, uh, a single one pager, we're not going to do site
links. Um, we're not going to do call outs. Okay. But one thing we're going to add here,
so we're going to, so I went here, it says more assets. I'm going to scroll down and I'm going
to add a phone number and add calls. So I'm going to add that to this, right? I'm going to go to the
website, copy that, put that in there, like, give us a call. Right. Okay. And I can now
this part, because it's a 24 hour service, I can leave this on for the calls. But let's say that
like I was setting up, setting this up for like, um, you know, like Francesca's tree trimming site,
um, like maybe she doesn't want to get calls all night and all day. So like I will,
I will set her, her, um, maybe set up the call part, like this little call add-on. I only let
this run during like maybe 30 to 45 minutes before and after close of business. Um, and then
everything else will be running other than that. So then we'll hit save. We'll say, cool. We hit
apply. It applies that to that. You don't have to worry about snippets, lead forms, any of that
other stuff at this point. We hit done. We hit next. Now it's going to ask for our daily budget.
Um, so it doesn't, let me see if I can do this here. So sometimes,
sometimes it gives us estimates. A lot of times it doesn't.
Okay. Um, but knowing that like Atlanta, it was like eight something. So, um, there's definitely
a lot of money in, in towing. Um, so what we're going to do is we're going to start off with like
$55 a day. Um, and then as soon as I type that in, I haven't agreed to this yet, but you can see
right here, like it given me an idea of how many weekly clicks I can get, what the weekly cost is,
and then what the average CPC is. Like, I don't know how accurate that is right away, but it gives
you a good starting point. Okay. So we're going to start off with that. And only cause this is
towing and it's in the Atlanta area. So it's going to be, and, and, and Francesca can,
can chime in on this. Like you make your money and a lot of volume and towing. And so you want
their phones ringing all the time. That's how they pay you. And that's why they keep paying more.
Right. Okay. And you guys are working on going to probably, you guys have a full website coming up
and doing the SEO and all that stuff. I'm sure at some point. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So we'll go ahead and
hit next.
Okay. So you guys see up here, you'll see in the video I made earlier today,
I talked about how we want this to be up to a hundred. Don't worry about that right now,
because Google's like wanting to add all these things that just going to take your money away.
But remember, like we're going to hit publish. It's going to take two days of policy review
and then five days of learning before anything really like good happens. So we're not, I don't
mess with them. When I first set it up, I set it up, I let it sit for two or three days. And then
I come in and then I make some of the recommendation changes to increase my optimization score.
And then we do that with this one. We'll pop on and we'll either record it and post it,
or I'll pop in live like I did earlier and show you the changes and how to get it back up to a
hundred on this site. And let's go through here. I just kind of overview what I'm seeing. Yeah.
Okay. And you can see up here guys, like this is one of the things like it wants me to add
site links to get my optimization score up, but I don't have any other web pages because it's a
single pager. So it makes no sense to do site links. Right. And I'll show you how to get around
that. And we hit publish. And there we go. So we are now under review. Here you go. We got policy
review and it'll give us some impressions and some clicks. And then it'll kick us into the
learning right here. Eligible learning. That's a five day, that's a five day process post
passing policy review. And then it just gives you a summary of everything.
And then I think that's it. Francesca, is there anything that I can
go over that you think I missed or didn't explain well enough or anything like that?
I think you did really good. The only thing that I can think of, maybe people will be like,
wow, that's a lot of money per day. But it is a little different because I usually will keep in
mind the first one or two days, obviously it's not really doing anything. And even afterwards,
but I do keep checking it to see how much we're actually spending. We just want to set it high
enough that it will produce, especially at first. Yeah. Yeah. And also re-emphasize on that point,
this is Atlanta. It's a large metro area. So this is not something that you want to do as a beginning
student. This is not where you want to set up your first Legion app, right? Nick and Francesca have
been doing this for a few years. They got a lot of experience. They get clients that come to them
from big areas because they know they can do big stuff. So when you do that, you get people,
you have to run bigger budgets for them. You can't run a $15 a day budget and expect results for
Atlanta for Tony. This is not going to happen. But that's a great point. We've had some other areas
where like, you know, just because you put $55 a day doesn't mean it's going to spend $55 a day.
This campaign may because there's a lot of volume and we'll make those adjustments,
but like we have the, there's the landscape or yeah, there's a landscape one we were working on
and we've had to adjust the budget higher to a lot for more potential clicks per day. But I don't
think we've hit the budget once, like the daily budget. We haven't even come close to it, right?
Yeah. So, okay. I think that's it. Okay. We're going to look at the group and see if there's
been any questions and then we'll get out of here for the day. We'll call it a day.
We have one person watching. So big, probably me. I think it's me watching me and you right now.
So that's cool. All right, guys, does anybody have any comments? Because we're going to,
we're going to kill this in a minute if nobody does. So we tried.
It will be pinned anyway. So I know it exists. I see that they watch this. I see the comments.
Yeah. It's funny. All right. We'll give them. Yeah. Thank you. I'm going to give them like
15 seconds and then we're going to kick out. So just because of the delay. Yeah. The delay is weird.
I always laugh at Nick because like, he's like, okay, bye. And you're like,
what? He just, where'd he go? He doesn't even finish the by when he sits out. I think it's funny.
And my videos are probably the same. I have to say, I've never watched one of my videos to the end.
So I don't know. All right. Okay. I'm not seeing any comments come in. So we're going to,
we're going to end it. Thank you again for hopping on and helping. Thank you. Everyone
appreciate your experience and expertise in it. So, all right. We'll talk to you later. All right.
Bye. Okay. Bye.